monsieur cazals et vous pouvez nous
expliquer pourquoi on a retrouvé vos
empreintes papillaires asik votre adn
sur le châssis de la fenêtre par
laquelle la fillette a été enlevée on a
vérifié as notamment relevé d'empreintes
adn auquel vous êtes soumis en arrivant
de votre plein gré leurs il ya douze
points de concordance ou monsieur
kadhafi ce qui veut dire qu'il n'ya pas
d'erreur possible
d'accord j'ai compris je en fait ça doit
être ma cliente de l'aéroport quand on
est arrivé chez elle elle avait pas
assez de monnaie donc de rentrer chez
elle juste pour prendre de la monnaie
est d'habitude je fais pas ça c'est
interdit mais on avait discuté ensemble
je suis rentrée chez elle je suis allé
aux toilettes et à un moment j'ai vu une
fenêtre j'ai tout de suite repéré que
c'était le feu allumé neuf avant de taxi
j'ai bossé pour une boîte qui est
landais des fenêtres dans toute la
france il arrivait quelque chose à sa
petite fille vous êtes rentré chez votre
cliente de danse et je ne vous le
théâtre mais c'est non plus n'avait pas
cru bon nous lie rires non hier je
voulais pas 10 parce que sur le moment
ça n'a pas paru important
je pensais pas que c'était important
butin